si josé giovanni
pourquoi josé giovanni alors avec vous
on est tranquille parce que dans aucun
des 24 films que vous avez dialoguer ou
tourner dans aucun des 21 livres que
vous avez écrit
lya deux scènes d'amour uniquement de
l'action et vos personnages sont
généralement incapables de dire je
t'aime
bah oui c'est vrai j'ai pourtant tourné
avec des femmes
ouais je fais tourner poser cardinal
annie girardot ajoie m6 un problème que
j'ai que j'ai eu avec mon père le plus
grand pôle de ma vie c'est que j'ai été
étonné de ne pas pouvoir lui dire que je
l'aimé d'être bloqué par rapport aux
mêmes faits qu'il avait sauvé la vie
et après je me suis dit pourquoi j'étais
bloqué comme ça et plus tard j'ai
regardé ma carrière et j'ai vu que dans
aucun romand et dans aucun film
quelqu'un disait à une autre personnage
qu'il l'aimé mais vous pouvez risquer sa
vie oui et donné sa vie pour elle
justement on arrive à votre père donc
corps ce joueur de poker international
propriétaire d'un bar à harlem à l'âge
de 25 ans
et quand vous êtes revenu en france
détient un gosse de riche votre père
posséder plusieurs hôtels et vous étiez
un des rois de pigalle pas votre famille
mais après le krach de 1929 c'est la
dèche et le seul recours c'est un oncle
un truand et la délinquance c'est comme
ça que vous rentrez dans le banditisme
d'une certaine façon oui oui c'est j'ai
su rentrer un peu plus avec à cause de
mon frère et mon oncle puis au fait
aussi parce que j'étais passé par la
guerre parce que l'apprentissage des
armes
c'est jamais très bon même pour une
bonne cause et puis ça a été de sa
capote très vite la vie d'un homme ça ça
va très vite
alors votre père delhaize sa famille
pour jouer aux cartes vous le mépriser
vous défendez votre maire contre lui oui
parce que
c'est loupé à mataiea car corse la
fidhop et assurent ses enfants et sur un
père qui était toujours effacé qui joue
et on est responsable on est prise et on
mépriser et ça a duré longtemps de même
de l'âge depuis l'âge de 10 ans donc
après ce mépris rester ça a été très dur
de revenir il faudra un jour à 8 morts
effectivement pour que vous commenciez à
voir votre père autrement
un braquage qui tourne mal tous morts
sauf vous qui restez et qui d'une
certaine façon payer l'addition à la
place des autres vous êtes condamnés à
mort à l'âge de 22 ans
et dites-vous sans avoir tué personnes
alors vous êtes mis en prison au
quartier spécial vous êtes tondu vous
portez des sabots faisait des chaînes
aux pieds il ya un brigadier vous
raconter ça dans votre bouquin ya brillé
qui s'appelle fournil qui de temps en
temps vous enlève les chaînes quand
votre père vient vous voir au au parloir
car il vient oui ça c'était et grâce à
mon père il était et une la fidélité de
mon père qui était resté quatre ans dans
un bistrot en face de la prison pendant
la prévention et pour pas qu'ils
entendent le bruit des chaînes au
parloir
ils m'ont enlevé les chaînes il risquait
sa place évidemment en est là alors vous
passez concernant votre père du mépris à
la la considération
un jour il arrive vous voit les cheveux
tondus il vous dira pousseront alors
vous êtes condamné à perpète
ça montre un certain sens de l'espoir
quand même oui mais je parlais à
l'époque je n'ai pas vu comme ça j'ai
cru que c'était encore une petite d'un
petit détail des tatas chaude et agilité
meudic mechouar plus feront un vraiment
je les malpris web et à partir de là
notre père va tout faire pour vous faire
sortir de là comme vous l'avez dit passe
quatre ans dans un bistrot en face de la
santé pour interroger les détenus pour
se lier avec les surveillants
et puis contacter les familles des
victimes pour obtenir des led de pardon
et ça c'est le plus difficile c'est très
dur se fait demander à des parents de
victimes des lettres disant qu'il vous
pardonne voilà ce qu'il a obtenu
ouais c'est c'est plus difficile à faire
c'est ce que je dis aux abolitionnistes
puisque moi je suis un abolitionniste
évidemment je leur ai dit mais
définie par des banderoles aller voir la
famille et delhi près parce qu'ils ont
un autre discours
ouais ouais alors il obtiendra
finalement la grâce présidentielle votre
père auprès du président vincent auriol
et la décision est prise 72 heures avant
votre exécution oui c'est ça c'est
toujours trois jours ces trois jours
trois jours avant on reste pas très
longtemps en france on reste pas très
longtemps resté dix mois je le couloir 1
eric il reste 20 en dix mois fin du mois
c'est déjà suffisant dix mois dans le
couloir de la mort vous étiez sûr vous
aviez passé là
non j'avais j'avais une virgin se vous
savez quand on nage avec 24 ans la ccl
très fort - physiquement moralement des
jours ça va ça m'est égal je me suis dit
disons qu'à venir j'en ai marre on lan
fini puis c'est fini on en fini voilà on
en vend l'infini
d'autres jours ça n'aurait 51 mais je ne
savais pas j'avais ni espoir ni les
espoirs vous comptiez les jours oui je
comptais les jours j'étais je tenais un
journal durée ce qui m'a sauvé qui
devait rester en prison jusqu'à l'âge de
33 ans malgré s'être grâce et quand vous
allez retrouver votre père vous préparez
des phrases parce qu'il n'est pas la
prison et vous attend donc vous préparez
des phrases pour lui parler quand vous
le rencontrez finalement tout ça se
résume à quelques mots il vous prend
dans ses bras et vous dis mon petit beau
gosse et vous nous répondez très
simplement bonjour pas vers cette
incommunicabilité persévérer c'est
spécial parce que vraiment c'est peu si
peu une phrase à dire qu'on l'a préparé
pendant mais on n'arrive pas à dire
quand même n'arrive pas à dire j'ai
essayé de communiquer avec lui plusieurs
fois
j étais des lettres que je recevais mes
lecteurs mais j'ai pas pu enfin ce jeu
pas pu y aller alors en prison vous
aviez commencé à écrire votre journal
vous l'aviez donner à votre avocat c'est
fn etc et qu'il avait trouvé bien et
qu'ils avaient fait jeu publié
d'ailleurs du soleil noir y voilà et
alors lui aussi l'été romancier oui
avocat mais romancier critique usa voilà
qui démarre ce soir c'est fn etc et bien
sûr et il vous dit pas besoin d'avoir de
licence de lettres pour se lancer dans
l'écriture pour être écrivain et vous
écrivez tout ce que vous avez vécu dans
un indice a fait le trou le trou que
votre premier livre alors se vivre est
envoyé à gallimard
roger nimier le reçoit et c'est
tellement bien écrit il croit que c'est
malraux qui l'a écrit il croit que c'est
un canular et dit c'est pas possible
j'ai beaucoup de kenyans rrl que ça
vient il a dit bon bain comme si les
univers concentrationnaire que malraux
avait s'était penché un peu dessus la
10éme andrew qui a écrit ça non il doit
donner un camus pour windows mais camus
les camus pour soi vous discutez si vous
aimez bien chez camus ce qu'il aime pas
beaucoup jean-paul ça si ça on savoure
approche c'est ça et camus dit animiez
de publier le bouquin le bouquin est
publié chez gallimard slam énorme oui
alors ce bouquin le trou vous en ferez
un film avec decker et le film est
présenté à cannes
et bien après la mort de votre père un
croupier du palm beach vous dire à vous
l'apprendrez à ce moment là tu sais ton
père était dans la foule et ses fiers de
toi mais il n'a pas osé
on lui aurait demandé si comme ici une
connaissez il aurait répondu non je
pendrai y aurait dit non non il n'a pas
voulu s'approcher de ma réussite parce
qu'ils voulaient avoir fait des choses
gratuitement sens sans rien recevoir en
retour ni armée re sim en une étreinte
rien ça s'appelle l'amour absolu
magnifique histoire
comme je n'ai écrit plein par la suite
il ya eu classe touriste qu'il ya eu le
deuxième souffle scoumoune les
aventuriers pas des films avec ventura
gabart
le meilleur pour vous c'est lequel
jusqu'à là haut film sur mon père
c'était deux hommes dans la ville à
cause de la peine de mort est maintenant
évidemment c'est le film que j'ai fait
son beau-père le dernier qui s'appelle
mon père avec bruno cremer s'appelle mon
père oui son chèque le père de gérard
darmon était jusqu'à son mariage il
faisait partie du milieu votre père et
arrière la veste et l'a gardé
merci d'avoir été avec nous à bientôt en
main